- IN WHAT UNIVERSE
IS THE FAMILY CIRCUS
BETTER THAN DILBERT?
FOR INSTANCE--OH.
YO, WHAT'S UP, MAN?
HOW YOU...
BEEN?
- OH, YOU KNOW, CUZ.
KEEPIN' IT STRAIGHT.
[suspenseful percussive music]
♪
YOU KNOW.
- ALL RIGHT, COOL.
WELL, I GUESS
I'LL CHECK YOU LATER.
- ALL RIGHT, DOG.
WHAT YOU SHOULD HAVE SEEN
WAS RAIN PEOPLE,
WITH JAMES CAAN
AND SHIRLEY KNIGHT.
- YO.
- UH, WHAT'S UP, MAN?
- [laughs]
[suspenseful percussive music]
♪
- YOU GOT SOMETHING TO SAY?
- YEAH, MAN, UM...
HOW'S DENISE?
- OH, YEAH, DENISE.
SHE GOOD, SHE GOOD, SHE GOOD.
ANYWAY, GUESS I'LL CATCH YOU
ON THE FLIP.
- YEAH, DOG, YEAH.
AIN'T NO THING.
- COME ON, STICK IT.
- I'M IN THERE, DOG.
- COME ON.
- NO, I'M IN THERE, DOG.
I'M IN THERE.
- TUCK IT.
- I'M IN THERE.
- I'M TUCKIN' IT IN, BROTHER.
I'M IN THERE, DOG.
- YOU KNOW.
ALL RIGHT.
[suspenseful percussive music]
- OH.
HUH, ANYWAY, YOU KNOW,
YOU GOTTA COME REAL,
COME CORRECT, WHEN YOU COMING
AT ALL, YOU KNOW?
[laughs]
THAT'S BASICALLY HOW I ROLL.
[sewing machine humming]
IF YOU AIN'T GOT--IF YOU AIN'T--